the University of Phoenix is shelling
out some big bucks
people often say that college is a scam
when they say this they usually mean two
things one they think that college is
too expensive or too they don't think
that college teaches enough relevant
skills that are actually applicable to a
job or career but there's this one
college called the University of Phoenix
that's not just a scam figuratively or
metaphorically but literally now
for-profit diploma males are nothing new
but usually there's scope and scale up
are relatively small and the people who
join these institutions are generally
well aware of the Shady status of the
school the University of Phoenix however
isn't a shell company that's located in
American Samoa instead they actually
have hundreds of massive locations
across the us including some of the most
popular cities like Atlanta Georgia
Austin Texas Las Vegas Nevada and of
course Phoenix Arizona they even had
their own massive Stadium seeing all
this you would think that the
institution is very much legitimate and
technically they are at the peak the
university straight up had nearly half a
million students and the university also
had plenty of distinguished professors
to match basically everything about the
institution checks out it except for the
fact that they're openly for profit now
if we're being honest basically every
institution is for profit whether they
like to acknowledge it or not if they
weren't UT wouldn't have a 42.3 billion
endowment and Harvard wouldn't have a
50.9 billion endowment also they
wouldn't be paying football coaches at
magnitudes more than even their best
professors but that's for a whole nother
video the point is that while
traditional institutions are also very
much motivated by profits there are
certain lines that they won't cross
simply to protect their reputation given
that the University of Phoenix is openly
for profit thougha they don't really
have a line in fact it just recently the
FTC find the university 50 million for
their deceptive practices which was
dispersed to 147 500 of their students
and that was in addition to the
university canceling 141 million dollars
worth of student debt so here's the
story of the world's most prolific
for-profit institution and the various
Shady practices that they have leveraged
over the years
yeah
usually when we take a look at the
history of shitty organizations we'll
see that they actually had wholesome
beginnings and the University of Phoenix
is no different the University was
established by a man named John Sperling
who had a pretty humble background John
grew up in a tiny house in Missouri and
his parents were farmers and couldn't
even make ends meet so there was really
no expectation for Jon to go to college
himself in fact no one in his entire
family had gone to college nonetheless
the cards would fall in a way in which
Jon would not want to get a bachelor's
but a PhD in history from Berkeley I
don't think you'd be surprised to hear
that he became a professor at San Jose
State University shortly after by all
accounts John hadn't made it big he had
gone from being a no-name farmer in
Missouri to being a respective professor
in California but Jon didn't fit in all
that well with this new crowd he hated
many of his students as he felt that
they didn't realize how privileged they
were similarly he hated many of his
peers at as he felt that they had become
too comfortable and at that they didn't
try to inside change it despite having
the power to do so this hatred wasn't
one way either as the university very
much hated John as well given that he
was always a troublemaker John was
literally the president of the faculty
Union and he was constantly trying to
defy the administration hearing all this
and surprising that Dawn stuck around
until his 50s but he did eventually hit
his breaking point after a rejection
from the state administrators you see it
John had been teaching a class for local
teachers and police officers and what he
realized through this class was that
there were plenty of working adults who
wanted higher level degrees so John
wanted to design a program that targeted
working adults but the state
administrators weren't exactly big fans
of this idea first of all the idea was
coming from John who was a known
troublemaker and two this cooler already
had plenty of students so they didn't
really care about attracting more John
however felt that this was an example of
the institution exercising classism so
he would leave his cushy job and start
pitching the idea to other universities
that were in desperate need of new
students and unlike San Jose State these
institutions were bite John would go on
to launch various programs at these
institutions that would eventually
become known as an ipd but accreditors
weren't exactly big fans of this idea
because ipd programs were designed to be
for-profit and had massive margins but
wait a minute didn't John want to help
lower class adults well yes but the only
way that you could get these
institutions to not only adopt this
program but to actively care about and
grow it was to offer profit incentive
but over time the pushback from
accreditors consistently became stronger
and stronger and eventually John would
be pushed to the conclusion that the
only way that he could make this work
was by starting his own institution he
didn't want to do it in California where
the accreditors already hated him though
so instead it he moved to Arizona and
established the University of Phoenix in
1976.
the University was by no means a success
from day one it in fact it was very much
a failure during their first year of
classes the institution not only had a
total of eight students a lot of this
had to do with the fact that the
University was unaccredited and had
tight stipulations on who could apply
initially the pre-rex stipulated that
you had to be at least 23 years old and
already have some work and college
experience but as the institution gained
accreditation and expanded into more
populated areas they saw greater success
and would eventually even become
profitable but their biggest jump
forward it didn't come until 1989 when
John began offering up online programs
this made the university a Pioneer in
online education and if you know
anything about the 1990s you know that
investors very much had a sweet tooth
for online products so when the
University's parent company Apollo
education group went public in 1994
investors pitted up investor Capital
would allow the institution to grow
faster than ever before or both
physically it and virtually their
programs included business Education
Health Science Social Science and many
more they also offered all sorts of
degree programs from Associates and
Bachelors to Masters and to doctorates
the university would even expand it
internationally by opening a campus in
Vancouver in 1998. all of this allowed
the university to grow their enrollment
to a total of a hundred thousand
students by the end of the century for
perspective even the largest public
institutions in the U.S aren't able to
reach such numbers but it wasn't
sunshines and rainbows forever investors
that don't invest in companies just for
the fun of it they invest the make
profits and investors don't just want
profits they want growing profits which
was especially true in the early 2000s
throughout the.com crash given that the
University of Phoenix was indeed a
public company one of their legal
obligations was to address shareholder
interests and this is what would set off
the painful decline for the University
of Phoenix
the university didn't just jump into the
super shitty stuff straight up though
like most things they're descend into
the darkness was much more gradual
starting with much smaller infractions
for example in 2000 they started to
drift away from instructional hours as
you were to guess paying a professor to
teach a class is obviously not cheap so
the university started to sprinkle in
some group study hours that would be
counted as instructional hours the
university would end up being fined at 6
million dollars for this practice but
this was just the beginning a few years
later two University recruiters would
file a lawsuit against the institution
for allegedly predatory recruiting
processes allegedly the university had
been paying admission counselors based
on the number of students that they
enrolled which is actually a violation
of The Higher Education Act for obvious
reasons it's not a good situation when
admissions counselors are incentivized
to act for their own benefit instead of
the benefit of the potential students
the university never admitted to any
wrongdoing but they did agree to pay a
settlement of 67.5 million dollars it
doesn't look like they've changed
anything after the settlement though as
they just became even more aggressive
when it came to recruiting the
university precisely priced their
degrees so that the entire cost of the
degree could be handled by government
grants and the loans this meant that
basically anyone could afford to attend
the school but that was kind of also the
problem basically anyone could afford to
attend the school this resulted it in a
bunch of people who weren't exactly
academically inclined to join the school
these people had a very little chance of
actually getting through their
coursework and obtaining the degree
meaning that much of the effort that
these students spent at the institution
would be a complete waste yet they were
pushed by recruiters to join anyway just
so that the institution could earn more
money from government grants one group
of people who have access to a bunch of
government grants is Veterans and yes
the University of Phoenix would
shamelessly Target veterans they would
allow budget lays head up recruiting
boots at military bases and it promised
the moon and more to these veterans at
one point the school would even get
banned from recruiting and military
bases but this wasn't until after the
damage had already been done during the
worst of it only five percent of
students were actually getting a degree
this means that 95 percent had paid for
nothing or worse they were paying back
loans for nothing eventually the FTC did
step in it and to get the university to
partially refund 147 500 students and
the four gives some debt but in the
grand scheme of things it this is
nothing 191 million dollars spread
across 147 500 students works out to a
mere thirteen hundred dollars per
student on average which is nothing in
comparison to the cost of tuition so it
looks like the vast majority of students
will be left holding the bag
foreign
wasn't able to do a whole lot about the
situation it looks like the media has as
more and more media Outlets cover the
institution and all of their City
practices it appears that less and less
people end up joining in fact enrollment
has fallen off a cliff from nearly half
a million 2010 to less than 100 000 in
2020. this has forced the institution to
scale back substantially in fact if the
university expects to only have one
campus by 2025 they even had to give up
their Stadium which has since been
overtaken by State Farm looking forward
I suspect that this downtrend will only
grow stronger here's the thing even if
all the reasons outlined in this video
Don't dissuade people from joining one
factor definitely will job prospects
even if the professors at classes and
the courses are all Stellar at the
University graduates would still have a
tough time finding a job simply due to
the terrible reputation of the
University if you have this institution
on your resume employers will almost
definitely a question your judgment and
wonder why you're joined a for-profit
institution so if you're looking to get
a degree this should probably be one of
the top institutions that you avoid like
the plague but that's just what I think
do you think that College in general is
a scam comment that down below also drop
a like if you hope that the students get
more restitution and of course consider
checking out our Discord Community
suggest for the video ideas and to
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on
the next one
foreign